madame laure de la raudière merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues en 2015 nous avons
été champions en europe dans au moins un
domaine celui de la hausse du chômage en
annoncé sens mille chômeurs en plus en
france alors que chez nos voisins
ces cent mille ans mois en allemagne
deux cent mille ans - en angleterre
trois cent mille ans - en espagne et
plus de 500 mille ans - en italie mais
que faites vous vous maîtrisez la des
grandes annonces
l'un d'eux caresser dans le sens du poil
les grands patrons et les sortes peur
mais vous ne faites que des demi-mesures
toujours prises en urgence quand le mâle
économique est déjà fait
comme dans beaucoup de domaines votre
politique relève d'un cynisme absolu
loin d'une politique d'action et de
résultats toute réforme structurelle
relève du mirage
à titre d'exemple la question du temps
de travail
le ministre de l'économie l'a évoqué
mais vous-même et madame le ministre du
travail avait fermé le ban à tout
changement sur la durée du temps de
travail et des heures supplémentaires la
réforme du code du travail vous initier
des réflexions encore des réflexions
mais vous avez d'ores et déjà annoncé
que vous ne toucherez ni au contrat de
travail ni au bio nalité de licenciement
économique le développement de
l'apprentissage
vous n'avez plus que ce mot à la bouche
tant mieux mais là où si vous échouez
depuis 2012
les entrées en apprentissage ont baissé
de 10 7%
vous êtes dans l'impasse plombé par les
incohérences politiques de votre
majorité et de vos ministres
pourtant nous n'avons pas tout essayé si
vous acceptiez de donner davantage de
responsabilités aux terrains et de
liberté aux chefs d'entreprise et aux
salariés si vous acceptiez de supprimer
ces normes qui pénalise la gauche et
notre économie
vous auriez enfin des résultats il est
encore temps de revoir votre copie en
profondeur mais aurez vous simplement le
courage de le faire et a laissé la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
madame la députée malade lors de la de
la raudière là aussi j'ai eu l'occasion
de le souligner il y un instant on
répondant à d'autres la question ici
même sur le courage ce le courage des
réformes si on regarde le passé ce que
je sais et je reprends bien sûr votre
phrase c'est que tout n'a pas été fait
tout doit être tenté tout doit être
essayée pour l'emploi et pour lutter
contre le chômage d'abord bien sûr en
soutenant notre économie c'est le sens
du pacte de responsabilité
la baisse du coût du travail du soutien
aux entreprises
c'est le sens aussi de la réforme que
nous engageons pour le code du travail
et nous avons commencé d'abord par les
principes et c'est le rapport que nous
avons demandé à robert badinter et c'est
ensuite le travail qui suivra
m'interroger sur le sens de ces réformes
mejia mêmes conneries aura l'occasion de
venir devant le parlement et plus
particulièrement d'abord devant
l'assemblée avec une loi réformant le
code du travail tout particulièrement
tous les aspects liés à l'organisation
du temps du travail
je vous rejoins sur un point c'est sur
le fait que nous devons privilégier
d'abord la négociation au sein de
l'entreprise au plus plaît au plus près
de la réalité que vivent les
entrepreneurs et les salariés m'a même
fait une proposition notamment quand il
ya une difficulté que l'on puisse
s'engager sur la voie du référendum mais
sur les principes puisque vous
m'interrogez et si c'est ça qui fait la
marque d'une réforme
robert badinter et sa commission ont
bien posé les problèmes et ont rappelé
deux principes que je me permets de
rappeler et il peut y avoir un désaccord
entre nous et au fond il est tout à fait
noble que ce désaccord que cette
confrontation ait lieu ici à l'assemblée
nationale où devant le pays le premier
principe c'est qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
temps de travail c'est tout il ya une
durée légale ou normale du temps de
travail aujourd'hui
la loi fixe ce temps de travail à 35
heures c'est le cas depuis 1999
entre 2002
et 2012 que de chage vous n'avez pas
remis en cause la durée légale du temps
de travail vous le proposer pour la
suite c'est votre responsabilité
c'est ainsi que le débat démocratique
doit s'organiser mais nous ne remettons
pas en cause le principe de la durée
légale du temps de travail et il ya un
deuxième principe et qui fera l'objet
d'ailleurs là aussi d'une discussion
ce sont les hommes majeurs ou majoré ce
sont les heures supplémentaires
et là aussi robert badinter rappelle et
c'est également la position du
gouvernement que tous ou toute heure
supplémentaire doit être payé comme une
heure supplémentaire va s'engager le
débat sur le niveau de ses heures
supplémentaires ça sera l'occasion et du
débat avec les partenaires sociaux et de
la loi il faut des réformes des réformes
respectueuse des principes des réformes
qui ne soient pas des proclamations mais
les réformes qu'ils soient utiles à
l'économie
c'est à dire aux entrepreneurs pour
qu'ils aient plus de liberté et aux
salariés qui pour qu'ils aient davantage
de protection merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole est à m e jean